you said in an interview you said uh you
know uh guys you question who's the
toughest hitter you face you obviously
gave the love to Reggie Jackson because
that's who you wanted to face off but
then you said you never had a problem
with home run hitters because even pool
holds he said you have one pitch every
time if you miss it it's over I'm gonna
get you right so you said something like
that and he said the guys you had a
problem with were more the contact the
contact like the Tony Gwen type of guy
so who were some of the guys if you say
contact who were some of the tough guys
man just uh you know in American League
a few teams they had guys that were they
just had great eye hand coordinates you
make a bastard pitch O2 and with
especially at Fenway Park there's no
foul Crown it'd be different pitching in
Oakland that's the most foul ground you
know so they would just they're good
enough I I tell them that guys in the
big leagues can put wood on a bullet
doesn't matter how hard you throw they
can they can spoil a really good pitch
so if I get an 11 pitch it bat with you
in the first inning now I'm not getting
to the ninth inning which I know that
sounds what we just talked about guys
going for when I said nine people are
going nine nine innings uh
then I might only be an 18 pitcher it
happens again I'm only getting to the
seventh so I'm throwing my two seamer
which I call a bowling ball I threw a
heavy two seamer down in the zone I want
you to hit it what we call the kitty
litter if you ever look at the place in
front of Home Plate where they water it
down really good other home teams water
it down more and they put more uh dry
dirt on it because you hit it and that's
like hitting Kitty liters stops the ball
from getting through the infield and
then sometimes the guys will grow like
at Wrigley they'll grow that grass four
inches high it's like hitting out a U.S
open rough it's not getting through that
and your inches high if you're if you're
a if you're a ground ball pitcher I mean
that's six four three all day that's why
that's why they you know you can do that
but those guys
um now Tony Gwen's a whole different
animal I face Tony in an All-Star game
and I try to ask some of the guys hey I
know Tony because I watched Tony take
batting practice and he played around
the world with his Bat in the ball in
batting practice
his first two swings he would hit it
into the cage
that he was in next two down on the
chalk line and left next two in the Gap
center field right field come all the
way around to to pulling two homers down
the right field line that's crazy that's
how good he was with where the ball was
gone so I thought the guys were messing
with me they go you're going to face
Tony Gwen though I'm a throw him a 94
mile an hour fastball right down the
middle I go that's funny you guys want
him to take me deep
they go no if you pitch him away he's
going to hit a double that way Minnie's
going to pull you I'm telling you
thought right I got I got a photo on my
phone in the All-Star game he was my
first one I thought right down the
middle he swings right through it kind
of looking at me he can't believe it and
then you know he ended up flying out but
it was a guy exactly you know we we I we
had one we had a Tony Gwen it was Wade
Boggs Bugsy bogsy
Bugsy could hit with his eyes closed um
with the sunshine interesting swing yeah
just he he's just a he's just a flat-out
hitter Paul molota was he was he was he
very handsy very good call yeah Larry
Walker did you ever pitch to Larry I I
may have I I met Larry at some golfing
events later and we never really talked
but I'm gonna say 24 years for sure I
probably faced him back will did you
ever pitch out back because I know you
exhibition game probably okay yeah baggy
so if we put Frank Thomas Juan Gonzalez
those guys well those are Al right so
you pitch with those guys yeah do you
have any stories with Juan or Frank or
just you know another yeah just good
hitters I mean you got to catch him on
the right day
Griff was tough Griff had some homes my
my story about Griff we're in All-Star
game together and I had the two older
boys they're little this is when
Nintendo was big up in Seattle you know
he'd get all Nintendo games he could get
so so so the boys down messing around
the lobby or whatever and they got on
the elevator they run to the room
we're getting ready to go over for uh
media day and they're all getting Dad we
just met Ken Griffey Jr because I go you
did yeah what's up he goes he said for
us to tell you that when you face him in
the second half to if if you throw in
some fastballs right down the middle
he'll give us all the Nintendo games I
go you stay away from him
the kid yeah I said you stay you stay
away from grip bad influence you gotta I
mean do Pat a favor here Pat's guy was
Juan Gonzalez was it not wow that was
your game no he's dangerous you got any
good Gonzalez stories for Batman I'm
pretty sure I faced him with the Rangers
a lot yeah
um I just you know he was dangerous he's
a guy that you know you had to stay out
of his little hot spot because he just
just he's just so strong
um
uh uh uh boy oh I was thinking when you
brought up molotar
um Robin Yount so my rock my Robin yacht
story I'm like right off the campus so
I'm I got a little piss and vinegar and
you know feeling pretty good and we're
in Milwaukee and uh Ralph house our
manager now Ralph you know uh older so
some of the scouting reports weren't on
par and
um you know I had a veteran staff Bruce
Hurst who gave my nickname to rocket
after I hirsty gave me that
um we had some veteran guys you know on
the pitching staff and uh so now I'm
facing Molitor I was getting out and
this Rob Robin Young comes up and I I
he's already won one MVP at shortstop
he's going to win another one in center
field right in American League and the
Scotland shows said we're going to play
more pitch him away we're going to play
him away
we're up three nothing and I throw in I
throw him on about 96 on the outside
corner knee-high
he hits it it goes by this year I can
hear it it sounds like spaking in a it's
not barely miss me it lands second row
dead center field at Old Milwaukee that
that dude oh Bernie or whatever's going
down the slide in the damn below yeah
yeah all that's going on Homer 3-1
I was like pissed off I was like man
that was damn good I can't believe that
comes up next guy molectors on I walked
him he got a hit
5 1
7th inning I think I throw one
it's about at least a ball off the plate
it goes by this year
into the bleachers by third row people
going crazy they pull me out here five
five three
I'm in the tunnel it's old tunnel nasty
tunnel there and I'm and they didn't
have uh covers on the lights and I'm I'm
hitting it with my glove I'm busting
lights and swearing F F this Robin F you
Robin yeah that's [__] I was
bullying um and and I got a group of
pictures follow me and I get upstairs
and I I get in the ice and this is again
no I don't think cell phones are and you
if you called the clubhouse you had to
go through the operator at the main
stadium and then she would Pat you into
the visiting Clubhouse
so I'm Eisen and the guys come up and
after I cooled off and hirsty looks at
me he goes
he goes Rock he goes uh let me tell you
something he goes a great game
he goes but uh because I said hey ain't
that you know I must have said he ain't
that effing good or something you know
and her hairsty and the guys are like
first of all that's robbing you out two
things uh he is that effing good and
number two is don't listen to Ralph's
scouting reports they're a little out of
date
thanks for telling me that now yeah well
you know him and him and uh Brett got 3
000 same season by the way unbelievable
it was kind of wild yeah Casey and uh
Milwaukee so now
again I'm icing phone rings in the
Clubhouse games over the guys are
shaking hands they're on their way up
and that's why she didn't pouching they
said you got a phone call at your mother
on the phone
my Mom calling the clubhouse I mean this
is weird she's never done this something
something had to happen
I get on the phone hey honey great game
great game and uh this and that she goes
hey before you get out of the Milwaukee
will you get Robin Yao's autograph for
him because he owns he owns you
my mom she wanted me to get his
autograph because he owns me what a mom
yeah
she goes yeah cause I know if I didn't
call you wouldn't get it but he's a
really he's a good player wow and he
owns you it's crazy by the way she liked
that what she was she oh yeah
National deal for uh Mother's Day and I
had tried and get back at her a couple
by the way so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]